she has the fate of Oscar Pistorius in
the palm of her hand and judge meseta
has shown repeatedly in this trial she's
no pushover she's told off the two
highly paid counsel why would she be
there except if she was talking to you
you know that that question is a bit
unfair if he says he doesn't know I
don't think you can ask him again and
again why she's remonstrate it with the
watching media and public possibly think
this is entertainment it is not so
please restrain yourselves I must say
this is very disturbing I am warning the
media if you do not behave you are not
going to be treated with soft glass by
this court and she's publicly humiliated
one of the legal assistants what's going
on what was that noise he tried to work
something I don't know and it went off
of the switch stuff I apologize for that
but the attorneys there he can stand up
in apologize for himself
she was born in Soweto 66 years ago
growing up at the height of the
apartheid era by the time of the Soweto
uprisings she'd already worked as a
social worker and moved into journalism
a dangerous time to be a reporter we
also went went on a match in
Johannesburg protesting against the
detention of journalists and she was
there we were all there and we're locked
up in jail for one night and we appeared
in courts there the following day and I
don't think that hey I mean I'd never
better one night in the cells would
tending to annoy Apple when Nelson
Mandela was freed she was already
working on her third career she went on
to become only the second black woman in
the country to be made a judge she would
feel inspired to say I can't afford to
fail because I'm a black person if I
fail some critics will say how we told
you black people would not be able to do
this her years of poverty and struggle
defined her her former sweater home is
now a creche for disadvantaged toddlers
and she's admitted and the few
interviews she's given that her
background affects her judgments I sort
of can identify with what these
youngsters are going through because a
lot of youngsters appear before me in
criminal matters and I do understand
because this is where I come from and I
think it does impact on my judgments I'm
not saying I'm a lot lenient but a more
understanding she's known though as a
champion of women's rights once
sentencing a serial rapist to a two
hundred and fifty two year sentence and
urging young girls to believe anything
is possible to the young women out there
the women in the townships where I've
been where I've grown up I would tell
them one thing that anything is possible
all we have to do is to tell you
out of it this is where I want to go and
I am going there and the woman known
simply as Tilly to her friends has also
shown her caring side in court is to be
destroyed
are you well enough to proceed miss
Thank You m'lady why 13 eyes now today I
happen to be watching the witness a few
minutes
well maybe about 10 minutes ago
he was touching his eyes I think that
this guy Pistorius could never have got
there much more sane I judged and aunt
Tilly because he's going to look at the
facts I mean as they are and the she'll
make a call whatever it is and it's all
being done in the glare of worldwide
attention her former boss insists it
doesn't trouble her one bit and I asked
her whether I could come for this
interview you know what she said to me
she said to me to hear that it's neither
here nor there and in fact she says to
me since she started doing this trial
she reads no newspapers she watches no
TV so it's neither he a judge miss Eva's
appointment to this case was said to be
random quadrilogy
but with global TV audiences watching
it's been as much about post-apartheid
South Africa as a murder trial
Alex Crawford Sky News Pretoria
you